Thanksgiving is overrated  it's [ __ ] overrated  every time I think your part you say  some dumb [ __ ] like that no it is it is  it's it's I'm the more I get older the  more I actually don't like it as much  it's still good but it's not I mean I  can't even touch I mean it's not even  close to any other big ones you know  because you want hold on let me tell you  why there's only one other big one  this is Christmas what are you gonna  throw Halloween in there no Easter's  Easter Sunday's you know I mean Sunday  no no but but like in the usfl a [ __ ]  Hall holidays  Easter Sunday is a joke that's like  I mean if I got another Power Rankings  they're slightly ahead of Flag Day  [ __ ] Mass where they go all through  the Psalms Palm Sunday I hate that whole  [ __ ] period Lynn this is my problem  why don't you give up raping boys you  [ __ ] [ __ ]  hey over